alright taste so just one day after the
quest for the sleeper simulant started
it's over the quest is done you can get
the gun now how do you get it all right
so it turns out as of today reset like
you said Banshee has a new quest it's
basically go do the safe request on a
slightly harder like light level and
then boom bring it back to him and you
get the sleeper slimming Lynn yeah
virtually no changes to the quest
there's not like another enemy at the
end there's no like burns or any like
weird twist just do it on a harder
difficulty whatever finish it and then
you get the gun and it's 290 so you'll
have to infuse it to really get it up to
the like that useful levels for any
given but I mean okay so this was the
gun everyone was really excited about
people all into this mystery of it turns
out it was just like two days of short
quests and then now the guns here and
like does it live up to the hype what do
you think personally for me from using
it I was very very underwhelmed very
disappointed I don't know if it's
because there has been so much mystery
there's been so much hype behind the gun
that like I really just thought it was
going to be good and then it turns out
for me using them like this is not that
good it's got seven bullets max right
now without having you know additional
fusion rifle on your armors and stuff
like that when you pick up a you know
purple ammo pack you're only getting two
more shots I mean yes granted i guess
the gun does britt and i've seen it do
like 30,000 but at this rate I feel like
I'd rather just have like a rocket
launcher or something it's hard to say
that I want to use this as my exotic
weapon right i mean it's funny it's like
you have each laser shot is like a
rocket but you're not going to be able
to clear an area like you can with the
rocket so I mean it seems like it should
have been in the middle between machine
gun and rocket but it's like way more on
the rocket level as far as camel ocampos
and the way it treats itself but I mean
on the other hand I think it's kind of
fun like just mixing it up at first I
was excited for sidearms because they're
just like if they're introducing a new
class but it turned out those just I
never use them they said
but I feel like this if they keep going
down this route like it adds diversity
and I feel like I'll rock this for a
while I don't have any other exotics
using up the slot so I'm excited to have
those moments where I do pull out
something cool with it where ricochets
down the hallway and Mike clears
everything I won't use it in the raid or
anywhere where it really matters but
like when I'm just like having fun or
whatever at the court of Orcs are on
patrol I think I could have some fun
with this yeah I mean it like maybe I'm
just kind of jumping the gun and like
from the minimal use that I've used it
I've been underwhelmed by it and maybe
there actually is some amazing uses for
it it's just that in the test cases i
did it's like okay let me try to go to
tanukhs because i know there's like
these narrow corridors where I think
it's gonna ricochet and it's like all
right it ricocheted like three times out
of the five times and there weren't
really any me there it just kind of like
bounce around and look cool but it
didn't do anything really yeah like
maybe if the ricochets kind of like home
Dan on an enemy or like there's no way
to control I'm like you're not Revolver
Ocelot or something like it's just like
kind of shooting in the dark what's cool
about this community those someone's
gonna find like that perfect use for
this gun in that one boss where you'll
always use it or whatever like there's
always that one time where a gun just
shines and I hope quick I hope this gun
has its moments yeah I mean maybe go
girl it does it does crit so maybe if
you like try two min max and just like
you want to be the sleeper simulant guy
like made it will may be able to work
out but for me like I said I just I'm
not very happy about what happened I
think just the mystery and the hype was
it was all there and then it just kind
of fell flat for me but yeah actually
it's kind of like a sniper rifle it's
but it only has three rounds in the clip
it only has like seven rounds total so
for go go off you'd be able to use it
for one round and then what you have to
Center them all right well that's
sleeper stimulant the most mysterious
gun and destiny for now so thanks for
watching
you